a teacher in Virginia who was shot by a
six-year-old student earlier this month
now says administrators failed to act
despite multiple warnings that this
little boy was armed Abigail zorner is
her name she was shot in the class
in the chest and she intends to file a
lawsuit against the Newport News school
district in the coming days and the
details of her allegations we have to
say are stunning tarika Duncan is
following this story for us tarika good
morning to you good morning the story
really is unfathomable the school's
assistant principal resigned yesterday
in amid both intense scrutiny and
pending legal action the school board
voted last night to remove the
superintendent now the move comes after
the attorney representing Abby's Warner
says school officials were warned three
times that the student might have a gun
this should have never happened
it was preventable attorney Diane
Toscano represents shooting victim Abby
zwerner Toscano said School Personnel
quote could not be bothered to act even
after several warnings about the
six-year-old shooter and she outlined
hours of alleged in action before the
child fired at zwerner around 11 15 a.m
she saids Werner told an administrator
that the student threatened to beat up
another child but the six-year-old was
not removed from the class at 12 30 PM
Toscano said another teacher told an
administrator she'd search the child's
backpack after suspecting he had a gun
but she found no weapon and worried that
he put the firearm in his pocket Toscano
said the administrator downplayed that
possibility by replying well he has
little pockets around 30 minutes later
Toscano said a third teacher told an
administrator that a student claimed the
suspect had showed him a gun during
recess and threatened to shoot him if he
told anyone yet again to Ghana said
nothing was done she also alleged that
when another School employee asked to
search the boy he was turned down he was
told to wait the situation out
because the school day was almost over
let that sink in
roughly an hour later Toscano said the
six-year-old fired at zwerner who has
since been discharged from the hospital
and is continuing her recovery Abby's
Warner was shot in front of those
horrified kids
and this school and Community are living
the nightmare
all because the school administration
failed to act
a spokesperson for the school district
declined a comment on those allegations
and did not respond to our request for
details of the school's protocol for
reporting incidents like this one now
local authorities say they didn't
receive a call about a possible weapon
at richneck elementary until after the
shooting happened I think that attorney
was very effective at the end when she
said let that sink in a second right
because when I first heard it I thought
the the response was well the day's
almost over don't do anything which is
crazy yeah and there's obviously so much
more to this story because anytime that
you have a care plan as the family
stated where a adult a parent is
supposed to accompany this child every
day yeah you know there's there's a lot
more to learn but it's obvious that
there were appears to be multiple times
when more should have been done to try
to figure out if this kid actually had
it seems like this could have been
preventable we can all agree it never
should have happened yes yes let's start
with that tarika thank you very much